this is beautiful though are you guys a
fans of country music so we the whole
entire season they take our phones but
they gave me a little iPod but so
anytime like the cameras were down and
stuff we were listening country music so
who are your plan
so Russell Dickerson we were playing
playing him Dan a lot of damage a some
Luke Bryan - a Danny chase by far I mean
obviously they're gonna have a huge
night so we're pulling for him in the
newest category appreciate listen to
them all the time - so I agree with that
you know we're so cute over there you're
actually taking like photos of her other
end on the red bar we're trying to be
more present so the less we could have
our cell phones out that might let
disposable one and we like how they turn
out
real film is actually real film like
does anybody do you know where to get it
developed you still take it to CVS or
Walgreens and they take care of it for
you I think we walk and it like CVS or
Walgreens yeah yeah we're good we're
trying to that was like the thing we're
trying to live as normal lives as we can
right now we're enjoying it we're having
fun and I mean going I'm being nosy
right now so how's the relationship
going yeah what's the next step anything
anytime soon I think right now at the
point where I had no relationship we're
really enjoying just trying you know
trying to be normal as possible but you
know we're impossible you talked about
we've talked about our engagement and
talked about taking the next step in our
relationship
one thing at a time though she just
moved a little and now I mean even knows
you're like what that happened in the
next you know year
am I am i I honestly if I was a betting
man I would say I would say would happen
within the next year yes really we gonna
narrow that down like short a period of
time I give you every day no honestly I
don't know I definitely would say within
this year is a good time frame yeah I
think she's blushing over there I'm very
lucky I mean look at this she's lucky -
you guys have a nice time tonight okay
yeah make a great couple
[Music]